let's talk about questions like can you
please guide me through your CV or can
you please introduce yourself so what I
would recommend you to do are two things
first prepare an answer to that at home
don't sit there surprised by a question
like that and then just like randomly
talking about a couple of things which
you did in the past because this likely
would then come across is rather random
not very structured not very
professional and second also be open to
then transfer into a conversation with
the interviewer maybe the interviewer
will ask you a question be then open to
answer that and then evolve also
conversation based on that this really
also just shows and stresses your
interpersonal skills that you can have a
good conversation with someone with a
client potentially in the future which
will also be likely something that
interviewers will want to see in
situations like that